[Music]
Bachelorette no more Ali Fedotowsky is
officially married the 32 year old weds
longtime boyfriend Kevin mono on Friday
at the Toronto resort to waterfront
hotel just outside LA he like respects
me he makes me laugh
Ali Dee's a special day to Edie just
weeks ago I'm like trying to write my
vows right now too and I'm trying not to
use the word like you're my best friend
but like it's so true I love hearing you
say that you are writing your own vows
mm-hmm
what else are you guys wanting at your
wedding we don't feel that a good time
so like we're having a live band and
like lots of open you know an open bar
can you tease your wedding party do we
have any kaley cuoco in there too Kayla
will be at the wedding but no not an uh
nut in the wedding party
my wedding party is two people my sister
my best friend any other bachelor nation
alumni on the guest list we invited
Jillian Harris I really don't think
she's gonna be able to come the lows you
know Andi Dorfman a bunch I think
keeping the guest list small was very
important to me roughly between like 85
to 95 people also it's important to me
to have Owen our dog be a part of it the
flower girl she is yes we're so excited
I'm actually currently searching for
online I like a little wagon for my
niece to pull down the aisle to bring
her so sweet
[Music]
you